hey what is up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial in the midst of a bunch of
hardware that's going to be coming up
today or this this coming week but i
feel like i should leave you guys with
some more software uh so i'm bringing
you guys another hd tutorial from the
free studio manager available at
dvdvideosoft.com and today i want to
check out uh this free audio converter
now i know a lot of you guys are going
to exit because you don't think you need
an audio converter but i suggest you
watch the whole video uh so you guys
actually understand what i'm what i why
i think you guys will benefit from a
free audio converter so to get this uh
this whole freeware manager here uh this
is the latest version just go to
dvdvideosoft.com you'll see the freeware
bundle download it and all these will be
grayed out and you go ahead and click on
the one you want to download and it'll
take you to a direct download link you
install it everything
and you are good you have it now i don't
want to have to explain that every time
i do a studio a studio tutorial but i
you know i guess i have to
so once you've downloaded the the piece
of software number 18 it'll be dark like
this just go ahead and click on it to
open it
and it'll come up like this and it's
very very simple just like the entire
rest of the freeware package you have an
input file an output folder and a format
now it does have a lot of input files so
if we want to go ahead and record
something
let's say we have audacity and we you
know we're trying to make a podcast here
right so we want to not only make a
podcast but sync the video of the
podcast uh with the audio so let's go
ahead and record something real quick
testing testing testing
and once we do this we're going to go
ahead and file and go ahead and save
project as now i'm sorry we're going to
export this
and we're going to go ahead and export
it as an mp3
actually no let's go ahead and export it
as a wav because the wav
wav test uh doesn't actually work with a
lot of a lot of programs like movie
maker some certain programs like
camtasia studio in sony vegas certain
ones won't take wav so just go ahead and
save it
and you can always double click on your
wav to play it there it is on our
desktop double click
and it'll open up in windows media
player and go ahead and play the testing
testing one two three
so now if we wanted to import that into
something that doesn't take wav like i
said you guys i i really do believe that
audacity gives you better audio quality
than if you were to record with camtasia
studio 6. so if i were to do an unboxing
video and do voiceover i would
definitely record in audacity remove the
audio there and then import it into
camtasia studio so let's go ahead and
browse for our input file here and we
saved it to our desktop
and it is called wav test right there
and it will take your wav now you go
ahead and select your output name we're
going to change it into
uh mp3 but
uh it obviously can be changed into a
number of other things
i'm going ahead and choose an output
folder so we're just going to put this
right on our desktop next to the wav
test and you guys will be able to see
which is really cool there are a lot of
formats that you can go ahead and
convert this into including mp3
wav and wma now windows media audio is
one of the more popular kinds that won't
be accepted by a number of others
but this free audio converter will
accept wma and convert it into mp3 which
is really compatible anyway we're going
to go ahead and choose our quality i'm
going to go ahead and go with the high
quality since i'm mr podcast and
everything and hit the convert button
now it's only a two second file so it
was done almost instantaneously
however uh if that was a longer file
it'll take a good 45 seconds to a minute
and sometimes higher so we go ahead and
close and exit out and there's that mp3
we just created so there's the wav as
you can tell by the logo and here's the
mp3 as you can tell by the logo and when
we double click the mp3 it opens up in
media player again and plays with the
exact same quality
uh and another thing is you guys can use
your video i'm sorry your audio recorder
built into windows vista if you go ahead
and search recorder under uh in the
windows vista start menu you'll see
there's a sound recorder we'll go ahead
and hit the sound recorder and i'm just
going to record something real quick
testing testing one two three testing
one two three
and once we exit out of this this is
going to save it automatically as a
windows media audio file a wma and that
is the only option
so when we do say this as wma and say we
want to import it into camtasia studio 6
it won't work
so when i do my unboxing videos and
record it
with the sound recorder and want to
import it i definitely need to use that
audio converter i just showed you guys
uh and
use go ahead and use that and import it
into a camtasia studio now uh before you
exit out i do plan on doing a video on
syncing of the good microphone audio
with the bad microphone audio because i
know the audio built into my my digital
camera is complete crap and i realize
that uh so i will definitely do a video
on how to use your good microphone audio
uh even though the camera does not have
an audio in
so anyway thanks for watching the
software video guys there will be more
hardware and software to come so i hope
you guys enjoy the variety that i
present you with and please rate this
video five stars it really does help me
uh and it'll definitely accelerate my
path towards becoming a youtube partner
and helping more people
so anyway uh thank you for watching and
thank you for uh checking out this video
and yes the wallpaper link will be in
the description if you guys want to
check it out and also i'll be tweeting
out my wallpaper links at my twitter
every time i change my wallpaper i'll go
ahead and tweet out a link for you guys
twitter.commkbhd
and that is basically it thank you for
watching peace